And just like that, you could be done
working in less than an
hour. What's going on, guys? Mr. Zinc
here. In today's video, I'm going to do
a step-by-step breakdown of exactly how
I deploy my power of 50 London strategy.
This strategy is beneficial to both
beginner and advanced traders with an
80% back tested win rate. Let's get
right into it. Step one, you're going to
want to make sure that you are on the
15minute time frame. To do so, go into
the top left time intervals on Trading
View or click the comma button on your
keyboard. Drag down to the 15minute time
frame and click the star icon next to
that. What that will do is highlight it
up here on your hot bar. Step two,
locate the gone and Fibonacci tools on
your trading view. This is in the top
left under gone and Fibonacci tools.
Click the draw down menu and go down to
gone box. Draw the gone box anywhere on
your screen and click the settings
icon. Highlight the zero, the 0.5 and
one on the gone box. This is underneath
style. Again, that is zero, 0.5, and
one. Set them to whatever color
preference you want. These are my chart
colors right
here. Step three is locating where the
London open and London closes. For
reference, that is 4 a.m. EST to 9:30
a.m. EST. Make sure you have the London
high and London low marked out. To do
so, I'm going to use the horizontal ray
or altJ on your keyboard. Draw out the
London high. In this case, it is the
wick from the 9:15 candle. And draw out
your London low. And that is the wick
low from the 5:30 a.m. EST candle. Now
use your gone box with the 0.5 one and
zero activated and drag that from top to
bottom and then drag it and drag it out
to the
right. Your chart should look something
like
this. Now that you have that done, go
ahead and delete your horizontal rays by
clicking on them and clicking backspace
or delete on your keyboard. Your chart
should now look like this, excluding the
trend line that I have present.
What you're doing with this strategy is
you are waiting for the breakout and
then retest. You are not trading the
breakout alone. You're trading the
retest of the power of 50 from the
London high to London low. So, I'm going
to go into replay mode. I'm going to
show you exactly how we would go about
trading the strategy. First candle to
open after the London session close was
a nasty 15minute $4 drop. That is a
breakout of the power of 50. This level
is now broken. This signifies that we
can take the strategy. We're taking the
strategy after price comes up and retest
the power of 50. So, we go to the next
candle. We put in a pivot candle on the
15minute. Price is starting to curl back
up towards the power of 50. That candle
did retest it. So, we could have taken
the entry there. I like to see the body
close as close as possible to the power
of 50. This would now be my entry. Stop
loss on the position is a close over the
0 percent retracement. In this case,
it's 465 on Q's. So, we go ahead and get
our short position out. Drag that down.
Our stop loss is a close just above and
our takerit is really wherever you want
to set it. Let's go to the next
candle. Small wick up. This is again
another pivot candle similar to the 945
candle. Fast forward again.
Still not hitting our stop loss. We're
in the clear. And now we should start to
see the play
develop. As you can see, a beautiful
continuation down after the power of 50
is
retested and price is continuing to
fall. And then our takerit hit right on
the
dot. And go ahead and delete that. Exit
the replay mode.
You can see how price is proceeding once
the power of 50 was
hit. This is how simple the trading
strategy is. All you use is one tool
that is offered on every single trading
view. Uh you don't have to be premium.
You don't have to be platinum pro
account. This comes with the free
Trading View account. There's no
indicators associated with it. It is a
free tool associated with all Trading
View platforms and plans.
Now, let's do some back testing and show
you how I refine the strategy to avoid
fake outs. Let's go to Monday, April
7th. Mark out the London low to London
high. Continue out to the right so we
can see how price action
reacts. Zoom into the strategy. Remember
that we are taking a retest of the power
of 50. In this case, price whips sawed
below, had a nice liquidity sweep, and
then pushed up and had a continuation up
for the rest of the day. Was there an
entry on this trade? Sure. If you had a
short bias, let's say you entered
immediately at 9:30 after the candle
broke, you would have been stopped out
almost immediately. However, we are
taking the retest. We are looking for
price to retest the power of 50 and then
continue. By looking for that retest,
that avoids all of these fake outs, all
these stopouts, all these candles that
whip below that level and then instantly
close over. Scroll back to another day.
Mark out the London low to London high.
In this case, we're looking at a 4 a.m.
open here to London low there. Drag it
out to the
right. So, price hit the 50% almost
exactly.
had two retests of it. So, we had a
break. We had a retest on the very next
candle. We're entered short. Our stop
loss is at zero or the 450 level on Q's.
And our take profit really wherever you
want it. See green, take green, is what
I like to do in this current market. In
this case, we had about a $25 move to
the downside or about a,000 points on
NQ. Another volatile move in this
market. Scroll back to another day. I'm
just doing one day after another.
London low to London high. Drag it out
to the right. Let's see how price
perceived this move. In this case, we
broke below the power of 50 and then
came up and retested it. So, what do we
do? We put our short position
in right there. Stop loss is at zero.
Take profit wherever you want to set it.
See green, take green. In this case, not
didn't even get close to our stop loss.
And price just continued to push to the
downside all the way until close.
this takerit that I just put on the
screen real quick. This was a
2.9R. This one
hit after hours at about 4:15. Let's go
look at another
one. London high to London low. Drag it
out to the right. And how did price
react? We had a break almost
immediately, but there was no retest,
was there? Yes, price continued to the
upside, but we did not get our retest.
So, this was a no trade. No trade here.
No harm done. We did chart out the
strategy. It did work for a continuation
to the upside, but we didn't get our
retest for the entry. That's okay. That
happens all the time in trading. Do not
get discouraged by that. Let's do one
more back test on this London high to
London low. Drag it out to the right. In
this case, this one's a little funky to
look at. In hindsight, it still
worked. And this would still be a C
green take green market. We had a
retest. Wicked all the way up and
managed to close under. That is an entry
at the 0.5. Put our short position in.
Stop loss is at the top of that range.
Zero. Take profit again, wherever you
want to say it. Wherever you want to set
it, excuse me. In this case, let's say
we took price action all the way to the
wick low of the 1015 candle. That is
still a 1.5R trade. So, if you had
entered this trade, yes, looking at the
chart on Trading View right now, it
looks a little messy, but if you had
entered this trade real time, at one
point you were at 1.5R in the trade,
1.53 to be exact, before you had any
draw down whatsoever, that's a pretty
damn good exit. 1.5R on about a 15minute
trade. Let's do one
more. This one should be an avoidance of
a fake out.
Let's draw this in. So, this one had a
breakout to the
downside, continued up. Price did end up
rejecting. So, let's go ahead and put
our short position in. Stop loss is at
zero. Take profit, let's say it was
previous low in the day. This one was a
loss and that's okay. It's not a 100%
win rate and neither is anything in the
market. Nothing is 100% win rate. But
this is just to show that this trading
strategy has losses along with the
winners. In this case, your loss on the
position was a 2.5R trade. You were
risking I mean not really much of a
move. That's a 462 to 464 move. That's a
$2 move on Q's. Maybe about a 100 points
on
NQ for a reward of about a $7 drop.
Can't complain there. But this one was
an example of a loss. And that is why
you set your stop loss to the
zero. That will do it for today's video.
I hope you enjoyed. Again, this is a
very simple trading strategy that you
can deploy either in the first 15 to 60
minutes of market open and be done for
the day or set your power of 50. Wait
for price to react at that level by
setting alerts. Check it when your alert
gets set and move on with your day. I
hope you enjoyed the video. Drop a
subscription. I am 25 point uh 25 subs
away from a thousand, so I'd be very
appreciative of that.
See you next week for another